preparations for wedding among the cow
two people in the village of tolong in
central Vietnam the water buffalo is a
present for the newlyweds people here
live close to nature and their
traditions like a long left edge or
again we get on that hunting was one of
our traditions I'm sorry when I kill an
animal but we live from them animals are
our food he used to catch deer and wild
boar hmm but once he tells us he trapped
an animal he'd never seen before boo
welcome to the Virgin cha bout we told
invisalign me at first I thought it was
a mountain goat died but it had very
long horns then I told the other
villagers and the village elder about it
I said Lucas animal had white spots on
his head it was a solo la consola
bissau Lola is an extremely rare bovet
almost completely unknown it's thought
to have lived here in the mountain
forests between Vietnam and Laos for
about 2 million years I dreamed of
seeing asawa and even if I got a glimpse
a two-second glimpse it would make all
of this all of the years of hard work it
would make it worthwhile and route ilker
knows the Sala only from photos here at
the far right in the picture the last
image from a camera trap the American
biologist has been studying large
mammals in Vietnam for three years
scientists first discovered the sow Lola
in 1992 since then there have been five
photos with this team from the World
Wildlife Fund tilter works in the forest
for weeks they're worried that the
world's last solas could die in traps
like these at any time nobody knows how
many Sola are left in way quang nam or
in Vietnam it could be up to 100 it
could be that we can come in her cell on
one hand so it's really searching for a
needle in a haystack these leeches might
help him they're a bit like thousands of
tiny camera traps
the leeches are feeding on these animals
in the jungle and the leeches are easy
to find usually they come to us because
they want a fee on us so we can collect
the leeches and analyze the DNA in the
leech to see what they fed upon from the
forest to the laboratory he and his
colleagues have sent about 20,000
leeches to institutes in China and
Germany in thousands of samples no
Sawalha blood has been detected what if
the Sola is already extinct just
assuming there are no more salois left
there are other important animals in the
forest that are critically endangered
and the leeches can can help us protect
those animals there's a monkey called a
red Chang Duke there's a tiger looking
rabbit it's really cool it's a rabbit
that's striped like a tiger it's only
found in Laos and Vietnam so it's not
just about Saleh although Salwa is kind
of the star of the show it's the rarest
it's the most charismatic it's it's the
species that's in the most trouble we
think
that's why people in the region are
being persuaded to hunt as little as
possible a long lapse family get money
from the government about thirty dollars
for three months they use it to breed
fish and buy rice to grow as a crop
lucknow t-cog it's not hard to cultivate
rice and as a rice farmer I don't spend
so much time away from home but I can't
earn nearly as much as by hunting my
lamblord ook li mochou Latino generally
known John honey how can you convince
people to protect animals the WWF staff
visit villages and explain using simple
games the aim here is to avoid traps
while blindfolded it's hope to Viet
Nam's biodiversity will attract tourists
to the region which would benefit the
villagers the mysterious Sola is now
known outside Vietnam as well yeah some
[ __ ] I'm sorry more than
anything illegal hunting and destruction
of the forests threaten our sola thank
you there I'd be so happy to see you so
Lola I think of it as a family member
dumb new don't get it it must be
beautiful daddy
what excites scientists like Andrew till
Kerr is a whole new species a relic from
the Ice Age still completely
unresearched at 31 he saw a solo for the
first time in the region's forestry
ministry workers had found it dead in
the early 1990s and had it stuffed when
I see a Sal law like this or even just
sol La horns and one of the villages
that I travel to it helps keep the image
alive it helps refresh that image it
helps it helps me it reminds me that
it's not just a figment of my
imagination that it's a real thing tell
her we'll remain in Vietnam for another
year then finish his doctorate but he
fears one animal will be missing from
his work the Sola
you